what's going on everybody this is Action
Bronson live from [ __ ] GQ
studios I just wanted to come here and
show my version of a stoner sandwich got
a big piece of bullet salami if you're a
young Jew growing up you have this in
your home at all times that's the best
part that a little weird end piece where
it gets old gnarly look at that I knew
it would work because they do all the
things that I love fried salami honey
chiles and I'm gonna throw a little
Columbian twist onto the top it with
some potato sticks it's a multicultural
stoner sandwich it's like some big piece
of about an inch thick so you have a
nice hockey puck of salami
everyone's asleep and I'd sneak in I'd
have to peel the wrapper very gently so
no one would hear the wrapper cuz I'm
sick in the head I know what [ __ ] I
know when someone's opening chips I know
when someone is eating a piece of candy
and they're not trying to share it I've
been there I've done that there's no
better bread than a good French baguette
it's a beautiful thing I love this piece
- I don't know I don't understand why
knowing like you see people do that and
throw it away I like that I'm gonna eat
that off the floor as a matter of fact I
don't play no rules
five seconds how long has been done
eating it why am I being so bad coming
and happy that I get so hype around
[ __ ] meat salami I get I
like that I get crazy well like my
favorite thing was going up a Chipwich
vanilla ice cream nestled between two
chocolate chip cookies then they roll
the edges of the ice cream and chips and
wrap it in plastic and sell it in the
truck while I play in the park the song
rings I run I purchase and I'm [ __ ]
happy for the rest of my life so we got
this beautiful French bread and it's
gorgeous
I'm gonna say this is Pluto some
European butter that good butter fat
content my good old friend mr. honey mr.
honey bear Oh looking good which that's
sweet is gonna play very nicely against
minced forcemeat of the Hebrew National
Jewish bullet salami just to kick it up
a little bit some pickled Calabrian
chilies you're good [ __ ] lathered me
in this and put me in between bread and
I'll be [ __ ] happy I'll tell you know
you throw the bread in there to butter
side down get that nice sizzling action
just a little base on the bottom of that
honey nice hockey puck or two some more
of that honey all over the place top it
with potato sticks
[Music]
that's the dirty rabbi and I'll do a one
patty I made it stupid for looks here
[Music]
the greatest thing that named this river
are you [ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
GQ this has been fun I'll do it any time
you want and don't you [ __ ] forget
about my makeover him